my man hello how are you how are you
good buddy little bit like that round
this is Mike cannon Mike how are you go
through the show man
oh thank you Leon are we on where are
yes that's it that's it we're good to go
again and I'm in yeah I put this thing
on and both suited up this early in the
morning good day New York I'm live
television so I don't look nice I try to
get them to let me change into a t-shirt
for you guys I figured it was more
appropriate but this is where I'm at no
you look comfortable
oh so comfortable with that you know how
do you know Sam because he's done so
much wrestling stuff yeah yeah he just
comes around every once in a while
talked about wrestling and yeah he's a
nice guy
the most lingering yeah but is he nice
now what is what is the feelings of
wrestlers about Sam I was there a good
blood on him do you think he gives you
guys the creeps no you know what our
world is so tight-knit that it's weird
when someone kind of from his world
comes in cuz he's a big fan right right
and so sort of there's this light and
this resistance to sandwich I'm sure he
encounters in his real life all the [ __ ]
right I guess yeah there's a little bit
of resistance but he no he sticks around
and he does a good job and so it's
slowly but surely everyone's like I had
Sam he's cool why do you yeah because
you stop seeing okay he's just a fan but
that was like oh yeah he's like
legitimately a part of things and some
exactly yeah yeah cause you know we have
plenty of people who would love to be a
part of our industry and they just don't
fit but he's a fan and he gets any smart
so it works out alright well thank you
yeah there's a lot of people too there's
a lot of shitty people that do wrestling
interviews for some reason like when I'm
when you're around and there's there's
there's just like everybody gets
together to interview wrestlers like
there's there's a lot of shitty people
and I don't understand why that happens
give me shitty interviewers or shitty
people both yeah yeah both both that I
feel like yeah there's just a lot of
people who don't know what they're doing
they're just nervous and fans are like
Sam but without the etiquette sort of
thing you know they've got like I don't
ask elite Russians but I'm so weird and
I can't seem to manage it yeah it's kind
of like that and he seems to manage it
better than what's a bad question you
get look at typically awful like oh this
um I mean I just get the same ones over
and over you know what I mean like I get
the people are like oh you put me in a
hole like and you put me in a headlock
and give me give me a body slam or like
you know and these are fine but I just
get them so much like the
how did you start wrestling or who if
you could wrestle anybody past or
present like I always get that question
and if there's a not a follow up to it
it's just kind of like when you do them
in a row it's like yeah all right cool
you know that's across three things off
as less locks yeah I guess it's always
been really cool always in really chill
and ask good questions which I
appreciate it well yeah it I guess it's
hard to be doing multi interviews - for
people not to step on the same ones but
there's got to be question that everyone
promoting something is terribly sick of
talking about there's also always those
nervous guys that you're like there's no
weight that this person works in any
form of media I don't know why you're
doing this there's interview but you
don't interview people for a living you
definitely don't just smack into this
wrestling yeah where you got those
credentials
I do not know yeah you gotta ask it a
certain way to look like you're in the
business like I won't just say to your
movie I'll say something like Seth your
movie the skinny that guess I'm talking
about it what no that's true no that's
really good that's what you come with
confidence right yeah that's almost
anything in life I watch the guys like
sneak right through the airport security
line doing the same way no one even knew
we were coming back on this flight it
was overseas flight and so we had to
like transfer our bags or whatever you
know you get connecting to go to
whatever small town so we're in Dallas
say so you have to like land and get
your bag and then go to the desk and
recheck it and then go back through
security and it was me and Chris Jericho
and we were sitting there and we're just
kind of waiting in line like normal
people do and this dude literally just
walks up he's got a hat and a backpack
on and he just cuts in front of Chris
and I'm like hey that's Chris Jericho
I'm like get first of all just as a
human get to the back of the line like
you're etiquette and that's Chris just
get back there and this guy literally
said no words to either of us he turned
around he walked all the way to the
other side of the line open like he
opened one of the the things like the
the separator of the row greatest he
just open it up went inside closed it
went right right to where you put your
bags in took his backpack off slow then
didn't even walk through the hands
overhead security thing walked right
through the x-ray one grabbed his bag no
one said a word I bet he was an employee
he was a hundred percent not always not
hundred percent
not an employ because Chris and I just
watched the whole thing and we were like
all right cool like I'm not even mad at
that guy he did it cut the whole line
but he did it with style so he's good in
my book you know he's good at that Jim
your manager Jonathan is very good at
that we had a similar situation last
time we were in Montreal we all Troy you
were there you remember we were waiting
through customs like and it was a really
long line and it was really early in the
morning and everybody was just miserable
and there was this other line that was
one straight shot and Jonathan I swear
to you did not have anything that we
didn't have yet a passport yet his
ticket but did not have any credentials
or marking on his ticket or anything
there wasn't even a guard at the other
line and Jonathan was just goes well
what's that line and we're like well I
don't know nobody's on it though so
obviously it's closed Johnny goes no no
come on we didn't follow it really is
crazy no no we're going to rest it don't
do this yeah and the next thing we know
we look over Jonathan is just walking
around the line yeah it goes right
through customs the best part of that
whole thing is tiel's it blows yeah yeah
yeah Robin manages no problem okay
sometimes if you just apologize enough
like Johnson apologize like you go to
the front line guys I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry just looking at the next unit
person like is something wrong with this
guy so let him wear whatever who so yeah
all right so but we cut in front of you
and Jericho who the [ __ ] is crazy enough
to do that that's what I'm saying right
literally did not care he had no care at
all didn't even say a word not even
apologist didn't when we said hey don't
do that he was just like like literally
no words mozi Dom his with his time and
day and just cut you it and different
cut in a different way I cut you better
yeah in a better way exactly it sounds
like but at least he did he did listen
and get out of the and get out of your
way he did get out of the line yes so he
found another way I guess we both it was
a win-win situation I suppose yeah what
was it like working with Wesley Snipes
cool yeah yeah it was pretty cool when
they told me he was going to be in the
movie I was like whoa hey what yeah like
that with least Knights like yeah that's
that's oh there's only one what's that
about
alright so it's like there's a this
futuristic sort of prison if you will
where they can use like quantum
intelligence to like tell if you're a
liar or so it's like it's like a weird
kind of lie detection device which while
we are doing the movie like I'm thinking
oh this is so
futuristic and then like kind of like I
bet that's not that far off okay I bet
they're just going to be able to use
like your biometrics at some point to
like tell if you're telling the truth
instead of how I use like the needle on
the lie detector so yeah there's this
weird facility that's been invented
where they can you know like a
futuristic lie detector and it's manned
by this group of people and they all go
missing and the system shuts down and we
don't know why it's supposed to be like
self-run system so then a team of
operatives including myself Wesley
Snipes and Haitian David Anibal we go in
and we're trying to figure it out okay
so that it's like a suspense thriller
kind of like whodunit sort of action
film and they've got a lot of old-school
like gore to it you don't see that much
gore in movies anymore I feel like yeah
I mean there's some there's some
violence yeah but it's also like it's
one of those where it's like it's not
like violence for the sake of violence
like there's it's good there's good
build-up to the violence like you get
your money's worth but you got to kind
of wait and be patient for it in a good
way
have you acted before I mean I act every
week on Monday night well yeah yeah more
traditional sense no this is like the
first movie type thing I've ever done
the side like from you know I did like
plays in high school or whatever oh
really we see did you like theater
acting uh so I decided I was going to be
a wrestler when I was like 15 and so I
was like well how do I be good at throw
wrestling I should take public speaking
classes I should take you know I should
buy dead weight set for my basement and
I should take some some acting classes
so I took a couple acting classes in
high school that's pretty advanced at 15
to figure out that like like that's a
very smart way of looking at the
business that at 15 you realize I need
to learn how to act to be a public
speaker because the entertainment aspect
of this business is huge you know you
would see I have my own wrestling school
now and I for me it was like a no
brainer it's writing I was like okay
this is what I want to do with my career
these are the things that it takes to be
good at your career how do you go about
doing that you know and obviously at 15
most people don't know what they're
going to do with their lives I felt very
fortunate that I had set a goal that I
was going to work towards and that was
helpful but then like I said I have a
wrestling school now and I see a lot of
18 19 year old kids who come in and
they're completely unprepared for what
pro wrestling is and I'm like what what
did you think this is going to be like
did you think you're just going to like
oh yeah I'm gonna play my video game I
guess there would be four
so now I'm like what no you have to like
did you not watch the rocket or
fireworks yeah seriously like you see
the rock what is the rock do okay I'll
do with the rock does that their very
least like just undoing him no I'm going
to be different I'm just gonna have
really good matches and it's just gonna
yeah you don't see that at 15 is it
impressive to like you know be what at
home watching TV and you see Hulk Hogan
and you're like [ __ ] it I know what I
got to do Shakespeare in the Park
that's a smart thing to have foresight
for yeah I suppose so I mean in
retrospect like at the time it just made
sense to me so you a shy kid but no not
at all not even a little bit I didn't
have any problems like talking to people
at all you got girls in high school no
so I was like uh I wasn't shy but I was
so like eff the establishment I don't
want anything to do with anybody all I
want to do is wrestle on my back yard
with my friends screw you guys in your
football teams and cheerleaders like I
didn't drink in high school I was like
completely straight edge like anti
everything else to be cool I was the
opposite of that because that was even
cooler yeah yeah but it like worked for
me you know what I'm saying like I still
was like like I was well-known so it
worked out fine for me in high school I
wasn't like anti-social but I was at the
same thing you were doing your own thing
this like a whole punk movement of
people who are anti drugs and anti Dre
to really women writers
yeah straight Italians called yeah a
[ __ ] where you might even told us about
that well it's so completely the
opposite of what you think it's going to
be but those guys are pretty [ __ ]
crazy - yeah I mean it just worked for
me it was me and my friends and I had my
small group of friends and we were like
I said just very anti-establishment like
I quit all organized sports after like
13 or like no I don't want to do this
crap just won me my dues wrestle in the
backyard we're cooler than you like it
was it was like an elitist attitude but
it like helped for us as far as like
making us confident as human beings in a
weird sort of way did you ever get hurt
backyard wrestling that's the craziest
[ __ ] you watch backyard wrestling -
surprisingly I very seldom got injured
back at wrestling and we did some really
dumb stuff when I was a kid you know
nothing like too crazy with like barbed
wire and light tubes anything crazy like
that but we surprised do that oh dude oh
yeah I think we're probably about the
same age and like when when we were
growing up like backyard wrestling with
such a culture there's a video series
that like kids could
in their backyard tapes - and then they
would sell them at like Sam Goody and mm
baby best of backyard wrestling it was
just kids that were like jumping off the
roof through light tubes and hitting
each other with legit two-by-fours I
wish they wire the mission for Jackass
do you know how they always thought that
the beginnig oh yeah don't submit don't
yes yes they must have seen yeah oh that
would have been a fantastic I know
there's probably hours of footage just
like they only got to see in laugh at
but yeah I mean we we we bought some you
know like we go to the local hardware
store and buy like you know particle
board and and we steel steel chairs from
like places and stuff like that where we
could and and I hijacking our neighbors
ladders and stuff and we had trampolines
so like there was an element of danger
to it for sure but like honestly we were
really lucky to not have any serious
injuries as far as and we would do a
show once a month here there for our
friends would they come yeah most of the
times we would we had our own thing man
our own little Federation and we we put
on shows and we'd like you know cut up
little paper flyers and hand them out at
school and like I'll come to a show and
we had a little donation box and we make
a couple bucks and go eat some food
afterwards and it was a good time though
suicide those guys but those guys didn't
become professional wrestlers you did so
like what happens then they all just
wanted to live realize it was funny
because when I was that age when we were
doing it like that was the goal it you
know there's like four of us and we were
all I guess we're all going to be W
these superstars this is what we're
going to do we're going to train after
we get out of high school and be
wrestlers and then like you know life
happens just gets in the way and you
meet a girl and you have a kid and you
need a job and you got to pay rent not
everybody had the support system that I
had and or the idiocy just keep going
when you didn't have any money in the
bank at what point did you start
training and get that level of
discipline because there was also a
stigma against backyard wrestlers at
that time and I think kind of still is
like people who say like oh you know I
come from backyard wrestling like
they're like well that's not that
doesn't count yeah so I as a backyard
wrestler I was very proud of what I did
like I thought it was cool like for
example when I was a fan when I was 16
maybe I went to a local Gold's Gym where
I knew the boys were working out and
this is an interesting story because now
I don't condone this in any way it's one
of the most annoying things in the world
like ants coming up to me when I'm
working
but I brought in like a whole bag of
pictures not that I wanted them to sign
like now you know Chris Jericho and test
and you know that's who is working all
these guy Arn Anderson was there like I
didn't want them to sign their pictures
there were literally pictures of me back
yards and I wanted them to see that I
was a I was awesome and I told them you
know one day I'll be up there working
with you and this and that
so yeah I I used to do that and but at
the same time I would do they react but
fright to be rare it would duffle the
only one that'll show you this the only
one that was like a jerk so to speak and
in retrospect now a hundred percent and
like on his side was Billy Gunn and like
he saw me wandering in the locker room
as he was coming out of the locker room
and he was a God Jesus Christ not now
kid and that was it and he like ran by
me and I was like Oh Billy Gunn why you
jerk now you're traveling with Jericho
yeah I know weird it is a very strange
thing yeah now I get to wrestle and hang
out with Chris Jericho all the time so
you know the Edge and Christian were
there like it was a cool experience but
the point was like I as a backyard
wrestler I wasn't one of those guys it
was like nah I know everything I'm just
going to do things my way it was like me
playing backyard football you know I'm
saying when you're a kid you're like oh
I still want to you know go through the
system so I still wanted to get trained
after I turned 18 I knew once I was done
with high school oh my god got to go get
like actually train so that I can
integrate myself into the system so I
wasn't one of those guys that was like
good no I taught myself I'd be a pro
wrestler because that would have just it
wouldn't help them here you believe this
self-taught yes self-taught Jim
yeah those those guys don't it doesn't
work out well so yeah I always wanted to
get trained so 18 soon as I was done
with high school and like it let's
figure out how to do this and your movie
is called armed response with Wesley
Snipes our response that's also started
Wesley Snipes it's in select theaters
and on video on demand August the 4th
and the video on demand is great cuz so
many people like I hate going to movie
theaters alright yeah man I said I just
don't like the process of leaving I know
I always eat fattening food come along
so like I would rather just kind of sit
home and it's a video-on-demand is
actually a pretty good way to see things
if you don't like a theater or stop
playing in your city yeah the on demand
aspect is pretty cool I think now
I'm going to this theater I treated as
an experience like I like you know yeah
I pee a lot dude it's embarrassing I saw
[ __ ] Wolverine active 17 piece 17
please child I just I played 17 people I
look at a picture of me and my duffel
bag I know I'm sorry I made 17 peas
[ __ ] 49 years old I should have
killed how'd you get through a whole
wrestling match without having to make
peepee yeah that's actually a good
question I would love to see the video
the fighter if she just should all got
herself yeah oh my god bless know one of
the one of the women yeah kitsch I think
it was just didn't catch yes she just
she catch a shot to the gut or something
we said during a choke you yeah there
should be soaked and yeah that'll and
you but you just see the roll over and
then like you liquid rains often imagine
you're like yeah yes Felice Herrig was
choking her the whole and she just at
one point I guess you're struggling to
get out and it just it can happen yeah
yeah I mean if you're just pushing this
yeah you'd be more common to have
something like that in a in a wrestling
match as opposed to the P it doesn't
happen the peas just like gone like it's
like did not even think about it like
you get like before matches I get
nervous so I kind of get that I got a
nervous pee nervous pee yeah as soon as
you go out they're done over and then
you come back like I don't even have a
clue at all I was a lie right but there
it is imagine back in the day when all
that cocaine was involved oh how many
people would this close to [ __ ]
their pants sure Saturn I know it
definitely happened I mean it that
that's more common because I feel like a
weird upset stomach or it's just like
you have a shark coming on you no I'm
saying there's all sorts of options and
then you take a bad bump or somebody
hits you wrong or just like you're like
I guess I can squeeze this oh wow gamble
and lose yeah yeah didn't Big Show have
a story when we interviewed big show at
WrestleMania he was talking about
[ __ ] himself in a magic it's Brock
lesner
yeah yeah yeah yeah that can happen yeah
I've been a punk had one on a Smackdown
I feel like against Dean Ambrose I
remember being out there for it and mean
Roman were ringside and we're like wait
did you yes I think he did because I
backed off it yeah it bad and match yep
sure enough that makes me like you even
more
we're proud of himself I mean I don't
think he was ashamed yeah it's just one
of those things it happens you guys like
what Henry Hill gets a laugh at on the
first time like you did it you pop your
cherry yeah you got pings don't be
ashamed is the part it's a part of it
part of the game are you worried all
about a CrossFit every because you're
like a huge proponent of CrossFit but
but everybody who doesn't do CrossFit
says it's bad for your body and I feel
like every time you get injured
somebody's like I try to Thomas CrossFit
I tried to tell them that date is bad
for your body I've never heard that a
lot of that there's a huge movement of
anti CrossFitters yeah I know I think
people just get that and it's part of
its cross for its own fault is the way
they push their sport or their fitness
as being it very elitist and just like
our fitness is better than your fitness
but the idea of it is just like
intensity over volume and and it's not
it's not like a race to just see who can
do the workout the fastest I think
that's what people have the idea of
that's what it is but it's really about
being super good at everything and not
just being like oh I'm going to be a
bodybuilder where if you're a
bodybuilder chances are you're not
flexible you're not mobile you can't
like your joints aren't you know pliable
because you're just tight the whole time
so like it's about being strong and
agile and you know quick and you having
good I think they have a whole regiment
of skills that supposedly the fitness
memo works for but yeah for me it's just
about having fun when I work out like I
just hate not having fun you know
working out becomes boring and
monotonous if you do the same thing the
same routine all the time and it just
appeared to me to be a better way to be
healthy and so here I am and I mean I'm
30 or 31 years old and wrestling for the
better part of my life now if you
include the backyard stuff and so I'm
just bound to get hurt at some point
it's going to happen you know and both
my knee injury used to be fair were
freak accidents so how long should take
you to work out how long ago CrossFit
session for me it takes about 2 hours oh
yeah [ __ ] 2 hours of CrossFit fell
getting now I wonder your workout gym I
do an hour I have trainers but it's an
Alex I'm tired I tell them I'm tired I
do a little cardio you know
yeah he doesn't real work you know you
can't tell the difference my body I mean
your collar any facial hair but that's a
that's right but you know what the most
CrossFit classes are one hour that's it
from start to finish like if you take a
class like I have my own coach who like
sends me my workouts in on the road
every week so like for me I want a
little bit more so I say hey make sure I
give this this this and this to get done
and so it takes me about two hours but
hour a half two hours but normal like
classes you would go to 45 minutes if
you work out every day no four or five
days a week usually well you would you
wake up and do it no I hate working on
them oh yeah I can't I'm an afternoon
guy like I need to be in the middle of
the day sort of saying like when I'm
home that's my preferred time some time
like 4 o'clock in the afternoon I'm like
ass it's just good now I'm awake so if
you got a mats at night you'll work out
at 4:00 and then go no so like most days
if we have like tonight we have a show
at the garden right so we're we got to
be there like around 5:30 6 o'clock but
I get done with the media at about noon
so I have like that window so I'll
probably just get it done right when I'm
because I've been up for four hours
anyway so I'll get it done and then have
the day to eat some food and get a
coffee or something and then go to the
building I don't like to do it like
right into it unless we have our TV days
on Monday where we have to be there
extra early so tonight's not televised
no non-televised just just a sweet live
event at the garden which is always a
good time sometimes better than the
televised stuff to be honest they must
film it though there's always cameras
there yes just for them in case
something happens yeah
now when you do that is it sold out of
there a lot of people there the garden
usually sells out I know we got some
seats left tonight so if you're
interested stop on by and grab some
tickets but it's it's usually a packed
house there where what middle of the
summer right now so it's not not a whole
lot huge going on so this is kind of
like a random one but when we do the
ones around the holidays or whatever
it's I mean we're sold out for weeks so
what else do you do when you're in New
York you have to go and do this tonight
so what else do you do while you're in
the city of a size press ah I do the
press this morning and like I said I'm
going to catch a workout after that and
then I'll probably just find some good
coffee and food and that's it I mean
that's my favorite thing to do is eat
and drink coffee I wish I was more
interesting but did it that's also the
thing to like about that shows that
there's a always another show so there's
no like big hangout remember these guys
after the shows because everybody's
piling into cars as quick as
whilst they can get to the neck or neck
city right way yeah yeah we'll see I
mean tonight's different we got a flight
in the morning to go to Texas because we
spend the rest of the weekend down there
we got our big pay-per-view on Sunday
great balls of fire it's really called
that I swear to you and and then but
yeah so I have a night in New York two
nights on you know but again I might
just go out and hang out with some
friends and eat some food like you know
just normal human things yeah I'm not
like I'll let's go to the club and get
crazy and just let's go eat some food
have a drink you know wakes up your
confidence more when you get injured or
when somebody gets injured by a by you
or in your match with a second one yeah
yeah I don't really I don't like to hurt
anybody that's that's a tough one I've
had a couple situations where I you know
stuff has happened accidentally and you
know I mean smashed John Cena's nose for
example a couple years ago and that was
like one of the first times I really
ever hurt anybody and so you hated that
I hate it yeah it turned out to be great
for this story no no it was great you
know and obviously you know John didn't
care and he knows how things happen and
stuff like that but like for me I don't
like to do that to anybody it's not what
we're trying to accomplish in our
industry and so that kind of shaked me a
little bit more than or the sting thing
like even though that yeah I get nothing
I could do about that at all like there
was nothing I could have done like that
bothers me more than you know if I hurt
if I you know mine when I hurt my knee
or whatever that was whatever this is my
body I'll heal it's fine no big deal
yeah and what do you go when you when
you heard someone like sting
specifically like you go and like start
apologizing right away do you go and
like avoid everyone and just try to get
your head together like no no I mean
that's the first I mean I feel like is
it I mean I'm a person that I just you
know I thing I do my natural instinct
would be to apologize if I screw
something up or I felt like I screwed
something up if I hurt this guy so 100%
I wouldn't you know go to them and ah
dude I'm so sorry there's anything I can
do like you need you know you want me to
go to hospital with you is there
anything like I can make sure that this
is the easiest experience for you
because I know what it's like to be on
the other end of it and it's not fun so
you know but like I said we're all
professionals we all get it so it's not
like there's any animosity recomm it's
just you know it is what it is but yeah
I mean my first instinct was to go to
him and to apologize for fusili and see
if I could be of service in any way how
is I think you asked for by Wesley
Snipes was you guys form any kind of
relationship or no what
was cool he kind of kept to himself a
little bit like he would eat catering
and stuff with us during lunch breaks
and stuff but he was pretty chill like
on his onto his own and he was like oh I
mean I guess him and Hannah around the
same age but he's like it's solid 20
years older than me so like we you know
was a little different but we did have
like because he's a legit martial artist
so like we kind of talked about that and
he had done Blade 3 with Triple H who
was like what 10 years ago or whatever
that was so he had like a little bit of
a relationship with him but it wasn't
like you know we didn't like buddy up I
got on a member if I got his number or
not but like you he was uh he was a cool
dude I got nothing bad to say about him
he was awesome and helpful to like my
first movie acting for Debbie W is a
little bit different term and you know
doing it for a movie so he was very cool
about like giving me little tips here
and there financial advice I didn't go
there I did make a really not a bad joke
but like we could we filmed the thing in
a prison like we filmed it in a prison
in southern Louisiana so I remember like
the one of the first few days we're just
all sitting around I'm like man can you
imagine what it would be like to just
[ __ ] in here I bet that would suck and
I'm like looking over and there is oh oh
you were just saying chocolate yeah like
I wasn't trying to be a dick or anything
I just like he was there in happen to be
in the vicinity while I was like
observing the surroundings and I was
like did he comment no no no I don't
even know if he heard it I bet he was he
was close enough that he probably heard
you're embarrassed by it I was slightly
embarrassed yeah that's a fair thing to
say when you're in jail though it was
sucked to come here I mean youyou were
right
I I was correct but it's a little like I
should have been more sensitive towards
right yeah this is not a hypothetical
for everybody and not everybody yeah
some of us have spend time here did you
when you're doing the movie is it like
do you get how that would attract some
people because you've wanted to be a
wrestler all your life but now you're in
this movie did any part of you go like
maybe this is what I should be doing the
only part about it that I liked more
than my current job is that I didn't get
beat up every single day right I it was
very strange for me to do like a million
takes of the same scene over and over
again and like like I enjoyed the pro
ss but it was so much like hurry up and
wait hurry up and wait Curtain way they
were so much waiting around I was not
prepared for that like I should have
brought my PlayStation or something yeah
you can only read so so many books after
a while you know I was like okay this is
a little much for me but I yeah that did
it was just weird like I like the live
aspect of what we do like because when
we wrestle there's an immediate response
from what whatever I just did like I
immediately get feedback on it whereas
we would do the scene and you have no
idea you have no I mean the director
says cut and a good job and it's like oh
okay
I guess that's it right right so you
don't get to see anything until not when
we I film this a year and a half ago I
think a little over a year so it's like
now finally seeing it back and it's
going to be in theaters and you know
people are going to finally get to see
it so now I'll get the feedback in it's
like that's just a weird system for me
I'm not used to that I'm used to the
live you know like the difference
between doing a stand-up show and you
know doing a movie it's just different
yeah one is alive and one of them but
bigger interaction and energy from the
audience and one is just yet with any
part of you like look I'm kind of
wanting to depart from what I do in the
wrestling ring is there any way my
characters costume could not look so
much like my ring gear used to look like
and that I was all fine I did whatever
they wanted to do is cool and I was just
happy to be on set and check it out we'd
spent a month down in basically New
Orleans area so it was just cool
experience I just wanted to take it all
in I didn't make I wasn't I wasn't too
much of a prima donna when it came it's
fun doing a movie it's like you just
you're acting it's silly it's not like
yeah it is it was silly but it was even
a good way and it was a different
experience like I enjoyed doing
something different
definitely not quit my day job you know
I had no aspirations of being the rock
at any point but I didn't mind doing it
and I would try it again for sure